hi everybody it's me Pete Holmes I'm
backstage with Deon Cole who just
performed as a part of the conan after
our stand-up series presented by Pepsi
NEXT Dion it says here good to see you
[Music]
great seriously fan a chiral appreciate
the extra mind
was he Union he is now okay he got to
get his money black shirt black truck
he's black truck can we do racial humor
were you a troublemaker as a kid I
didn't write this Oh sounds like loaded
no I wasn't were you class clown class
no I wasn't I was only child which made
me question a lot of things what is the
correlation between being an only child
and being a questioning soul if you're
the only child yeah
and your mother works a lot yeah you're
alone a lot they're gonna question a lot
of today and so it turned from questions
to I guess some material it was the
south side of Chicago version of Walter
yes you were walking around barefoot
writing poetry wall in his there was
this weird white man henry david thoreau
sounds like a serial killer okay
and he was like I'm tired of all this
technology so he went to a pond to be
aggressively aggressively white and
crunchy like a hippie did you play any
sports as a child yes
football football and gymnastics why
were you taking gymnastics did you fight
crime No Oh Larry is that money that's a
comedian laughing by the way yeah when a
comic says hilarious
it really was funny right I felt good
about them know like I got into
gymnastics because like the area that I
grew up in we used to have like this
like real bad mattress that these people
threw away in the building next to us
and threw it in alley yeah and we used
to always just jump on this mattress me
and these kids
it lets us doing flips and flips and
flips and then we start doing it without
the mattress and then we just always did
it
you can do a free-standing well yeah I
used to do floor rings vault parallel
bars I don't know any of those words you
took the mat away I could do flips
without protect all the way up into high
school I also tried out for the Olympics
did you get it
no I broke my face what part of the body
is the face this hair how did you break
rice I was doing a flip a forward flip
and I kept doing these flips I was going
to tuck like this and I land it and my
knees hit the ground and my head kept
going and I cracked my face on my knee
and I was the end of my gymnastics
career and then I started smoking weed
and drinking this is the last leg we're
gonna do quick word association Dion I
didn't I only have another word writing
Chicago Chicago just what comes to mind
me yep wrong answers Los Angeles work
comedy love yeah
hipster don't want to fight with me
don't want to fight with you I'll never
hang out with that hipsters just in case
we get into a fight they won't help
that's true the jeans are too tight I
can't hang with nobody unless they're
ready to get down fight in fact I guess
you could say the tightness of the jeans
willingness to back up your friend yeah
cut up cut off the blood and the legs
that's right feng shui
I got pointment for all that yeah
Kardashian bad as hell okay me and every
other black man on planet Richard Pryor
greatest ever
I agree Tiger Woods greatest Smasher
ever yeah he took out his 3-wood he did
it the right way you you that like I
have almost a billion dollars you do it
like that
only thing he should have did is told
his wife what kind of dude he was right
so she didn't do what she was getting
into sorry I smell like a Denny's
waitress
that turns him on though Dion thank you
so much for being a part of the conan
after our stand-up series thank you have
great sex was fun Pepsi NEXT yeah I wish
they can see the other behind-the-scenes
footage of the behind the scenes footage
well then you can get that next that's
just me in the bathroom crying ah that's
hot though
[Music]